President Trump taking time during his
visit to the UK to sit down for a candid
interview with Piers Morgan on the good
morning Britain show he opened up about
his trip conversations with the Queen
and how his late mother would have
reacted I will say that my mother would
have been very proud she was a
tremendous fan of this country and she
was a she loves Scotland she grew up in
Stornoway she loved the Royal she loved
the Queen and I always noticed whenever
anything was on about the Queen
she would watch she was a big fan of the
detail I told her last night she was
very honored we had a great rapport we
had we had a conversation that lasted
for an hour and a half non-stop he also
took the moment to clarify a
controversial comment about Megan Merkel
the Duchess of Sussex this meghamala
business yeah do you think Megan
markle's nasty will no no you know the
question was asked to me and I didn't
know that she said anything bad about me
it sounds like she did and that's okay I
mean they joined the crowd right you've
heard about that too with yourself I
know that right but it seems like she
had and they said some of the things
that she said and it's actually on tape
and I said wow I didn't know she was
nasty I was referring to her she's a
nice guy said she was nasty about me and
essentially I didn't know she was nasty
about me so I said but you know what
she's doing a good job I hope she enjoys
her life obviously the president's trip
was covered heavily here in the United
States
Trump blasting the quote corrupt media
for not being fair those comments not
without merit let's look at the stark
difference in how the British media is
covering the president compared to the
US media UK outlets opting for more
positive headlines touting trumps praise
of eternal friendship common values and
the treasured friendship between the
u.s. and the UK but the US media they
just can't seem to help themselves once
again going on the attack narcissism
don't mix well with diplomacy who knew
the Brits absolutely know how to troll
the president they know how to get under
his skin and they did it with you know
with with style with spectacle he likes
the idea
a king perhaps he likes the idea of
being a king oh he's walking around like
he wants to be the king that's his house
like he's the king they didn't just say
you know it's his subjects do this to
this all right Dana I mean I think it's
clear why the British media likes it
when the US president comes it's because
it solidifies the relationship between
the two countries that have a lot in
common if you think you know following
British politics over the past year it's
not been easy and they're just there now
they have a prime minister that's
leading they have a new election they
haven't done brexit that's like that is
a big mess and then for the last several
days
they are the host to the leader of the
free world it could not have gone better
I think UK's perspective and also from
the White House's perspective they had a
great time and I think that a lot of
this for US media is that it's pre-baked
that the president's gonna have a bad
trip he's gonna screw something up he's
gonna have a domestic problem back home
and that's actually kind of not happened
of course you know Peters British he
said that there is a more of a
groundswell of support for President
Trump in Britain that a lot of times
people who wanted to leave the European
Union get ignored in the media this is
it's a very similar story and that they
wish that Theresa May had been a little
bit more like President Trump when she
was fighting with the EU about leaving
because she kept trying to like
accommodate and they don't want to
accommodate Europe anymore so I don't
know where it goes from here but I do
think that the UK had a very successful
visit but the president has a lot to be
proud of and there's some more to come
Greg I'd like to take this opportunity
to play some video for you of the
president trying on a hat for Winston
Churchill thank you even would like to
present you with a Churchill has affairs
that's I never knew you had that kind of
Sensibility it's very good let me try
this on these so I don't they'll be
great so it's a little big that's what
we can get that that's fun so absolutely
see how that looks
I think I think Churchill little Winston
shrunk I think I think Winston look much
better than what do you think about the
Hat Greg would you have done that he
should be wearing a black hat because
he's a villain hey I never liked Piers
Morgan when he was on CNN but I like him
on that show yeah so it's definitely CNN
I let's talk about the delusion the news
to delusion there was one of the women
in the and the montage that said the
Brits really know how to get under his
skin so that's a delusion she there was
never any sign that anything was under
his skin but she sees it in her head and
projects it that's a delusion there's an
article on CNN's website by crystallizer
that we all got sent around at third
listed 31 quotes from Donald Trump and
after each quote his head was exploding
you could hear him pulling at his hair
going oh my god he's like the neighbor
from bewitched right he's going
absolutely nuts so this is what I keep
talking about when you focus on the
words you could you create your very own
mental health problem that nobody else
can see if you focus on the deeds
however we're throwing out with trade
jobs GDP North Korea China what we're
doing with opioids uh our military
strength adverse drinking the military
footprint things this is a golden age
but if you keep focusing on the words
you end up having these delusions like
you do on CNN and and I like this young
woman that was on that other show also
I'd like to say that I've said before
the Trump is a news potato you know he
you can make him into any meal french
fries gratin you could also make him
into a shepherd's pie because he served
it up he served it up you how hard he
blend up news and entertainment what
would you make the president until if
you were playing mr. Potato Head game
here
well shepherd's pie that was quite you
know you're a sophisticated guy not what
you think by the way I guess I saw this
visual differently because I I read
where the president was talking to
Teresa may about well you know we could
have a trade deal with the US we'd
include the British health care system
which absolutely set here a fire in
Britain people's at what he wants to now
bring American private enterprise into
our much beloved you know public sector
health care system so I think people
were upset about that and with the Megan
Markel stuff again you know he says he
was talking about her comment I just say
is this a kind of difference without
distinction because I think he has a
history of calling people like Hillary
Clinton a nasty woman right he said this
about senator
with Warren he said this about Kamala
Harris he says Omarosa is a dog he says
Rosie O'Donnell's a dog you think yeah I
know how this guy talks and speaks about
people who are critical or have strong
differences with him so to me you know
it's okay so that's my point that also
in other words she's the kind of person
who makes nasty comments to him that's
we told you what he's thinking you have
to read it but I just think that you
guys say oh you know everything went so
smoothly but I think that it you know
you look at the protest he says he did
ever saw it he saw people caring he said
oh but I see that they had all fairness
as to what they might have been exactly
in considering the outrage and and the
point that and the build-up by the media
the Mayor of London was making you would
think that the entire country is dead
set against this president and he is as
bad as Hitler and that was the film
available subtext of Sadiq Khan's op-ed
that he wrote saying Britain should not
be rolling out the red carpet for this
president but what I want to point out
kind of in contrast aside from how you
feel about the President and how he has
jostled the world stage and u.s.
politics are very dynamic very very
fluid we know we may have a new
president in a year and a half but we
may have the same president for another
five and a half years but someone who
has been there through many
administrations is the queen yeah and
you have to look at her reaction and her
reaction was not one of disgust or
disdain or snobbery she was truly giddy
and she obviously Joe enjoyed being in
his presence because she knows this too
shall pass and not to get too wrapped up
in too emotional and too reactive to
this figure who has created all sorts of
emotional reactions from people on both
sides of hatred and beloved for the
president and and I really enjoyed
watching her because I don't think she
was trolling him I think she had a great
time and I think she did her point in
her life where you know from Eisenhower
to Trump she she has seen the political
gamut run here in the United States well
I don't think you thought she might be
trolling him or that with someone say oh
I
I think that was that was the point of
one of the the first commenters from the
US then well the Brits really know how
to troll the president that wasn't
trolling that was someone who's been
through it who has perspective who
actually had a pretty good time yes
Kennedy knows trolling no I am actually
a troll yeah I live under a bridge that
was the joke thanks for explaining my
joke
not just the bridge comment cause he's
very short